it's Biden's big night the president
trying to sell America on his agenda in
a second term at the State of the Union
but will the American people buy his
defective product Joe will attempt The
Impossible and try and convince
Americans that all their hardships are
just a mirage you see in Biden's World
inflation is not at a four decade high
and 64 percent of Americans are not
living paycheck to paycheck as a matter
of fact Democrats are already cheering
on the con job Chuck Schumer's wedding
himself with excitement
I think the president will do a very
good job at selling the accomplishment
from what I hear there are like 40
million people to watch it's not the
Super Bowl but it's a heck of a lot of
people
and Saki thinks her old boss can seal
the deal during Story Time with Joe
I think what people are going to get
tomorrow night is Big Progressive bold
Joe Biden he's done a lot of stuff
accomplished a lot of stuff and nobody
really knows about all those things and
they can't make the speech about that
they know that you can't do a listicle
of all the things you've done people
will tune out they don't want to know
about data what he needs to do is tell a
story Joe Biden is an amazing
Storyteller I mean you sit in the Oval
Office screen can tell you and you can
storytell for six hours he needs to do
that in the speech tonight Biden's also
expected to call for his trademark Unity
tonight hope he's got a different
speechwriter from last Friday
the extreme maggot Republicans in the
House of Representatives and made it
clear they intend to put it all at risk
they intend to destroy the pro this is
not your father's Republican Party
no really think about it these aren't
conservatives
these are conservatives these disruptive
people
they intend to destroy the progress we
made
so Dana Perino Who's down in D.C can she
feel the excitement in the air well a
lot of streets are closed off so that's
usually a sign that something's about to
happen and there's some Buzz here in the
fox DC Bureau which is always good I
think you hit you said something Jesse
that I picked up on a little bit and
that is that the White House really does
intend at least in the previews to say
this is a speech about unity and he will
continue to spread his Unity message and
they might be sincere right when they
say that but if you've been paying
attention at all and we know that our
viewers have that's going to sound a
little Hollow and unity might just be in
the eye of the beholder because what's
happening the very next day well the
president will be going to Wisconsin and
Florida and one of the things he's going
to do is assure everybody that it's the
Democrats who are going to protect
Medicare and Social Security so we know
where those attack lines are going to go
I think that you'll see some things
tonight that every buddy could cheer for
and you know everybody likes democracy
everybody like for example if he talks
about the ukrainians and their bravery
there's a lot of interesting guests and
important people that are going to be in
the box tonight but that's true for both
sides of the aisle in fact Ennis Cantor
Freedom will be one of the guests of
Kevin McCarthy so you have a contrast
there to pull from but I think the thing
that will be very interesting to see is
if the president gives any indication
about what he wants to do in the next
two years and Beyond a lot of
speculation because this is a speech
that really anchors in my opinion what
he is going to do if he decides to run
for reelection we know that this is the
preview speech to that one so Judge
Jeanine we hear about how important it
is for President Biden to tell a story
doesn't matter if the story is true or
not but he just has to tell a story you
know I feel like we could hear some
Whoppers this evening well if he does
tell a story about Corn Pop and some of
the other stuff it'll certainly be a
Whopper but one something you can be
sure of Joe Biden is going to be like a
used car salesman who's trying to sell
us a jalopy he's going to tell us
tonight that the economy is in great
shape that uh that jobs are back and the
economy's back and the prices of gas are
down and we all we owe all this to Joe
Biden that that everything is is glowing
on the economic scale the problem is
that Americans don't feel that way and
unfortunately uh when you think about it
he really has no record to run on in
spite of what gen saki says and even
during the midterms what he ran on was
the Maga hate and it was everybody
else's fault it was a Republican's fault
it was Putin's fault it was inflation
was Trump's fault remember amen it was
high when I got here except it was 1.6
when he got there and nine percent while
he was there and what we haven't seen
that we didn't see in the midterms and
we haven't seen from Joe Biden is an
attempt to Unity he has tried to Gin up
division from the beginning and
hopefully he won't repeat what he did
just what 48 72 hours ago on Friday
night when he ginned up the Maga hate so
we're not we haven't heard anything
about the empathy that got him into
office over inflation and gas prices and
covet and all that but I think what
Americans really want to hear is they
want to hear that America is reasserting
its leadership in the world we're not
going to hear it or if it does if he
does it won't ring true and the truth is
that only 37 percent of Democrats want
him to run again even though he's going
to see this as a soft launch for 2024.
and I I was reading today that he's got
these Palm cards that that every
candidate your local Town Council
candidate had popcorn to list all their
accomplishments I think that's probably
so Joe can remember the story so Harold
I really don't want to hear a listicle
as gen Zaki said that will put us all to
sleep if you could advise the president
you know how good your political
instincts are Harold Ford Jr what would
you tell the president to make his Core
theme about
well I wish I was around a table with
you guys a couple things one I think
that um I think Dana know that in terms
of what you think about when you're
giving a state of the union and here he
is at his third state of the union it's
likely this will be the precursor for
the race so Jesse your question portends
what I think the speech writers and
others and the Press officer at the
White House is thinking about and
jensaki is right no one wants a list
he's got a he's got to tell a story Now
list has got to be encased in that story
and then he's got to address some of the
things the judge raised those numbers
are real numbers uh you can't tell
someone they're doing better if they're
not if they don't believe they're doing
better you can tell them what you've
done to try to make their lives better
and then what you plan to do over the
next year too and how you intend to work
with Republicans and Democrats alike who
want to meet you in who are open-minded
enough to want to negotiate and build a
consensus this speech having gone to a
lot of them uh it's about theatrics uh
Dana's right there are a lot of people
be in the chamber that night the
president will point to a lot of them uh
the cameras will will even spring to
those who are with Republicans might be
with McCarthy for that matter even in
the president's box in a lot of ways
it's a feel good speech for the country
and you'll see Democrats clap when he
says something that they like and
Republicans sit down and Republicans May
clap uh to be to be a little snippy with
him during times of the speech what I do
hope is they don't they don't they all
remember that the cameras are on them
and then as much as there may be some
partisan divide at the end of the day
the country does want to be unified and
the president the president will have an
opportunity Before 40 million people a
night to give us a vision to give us a
sense of what he's done and why that's
why what he has done is right and
putting us on the right path and more
importantly what's the next two years
going to look like and hopefully he does
that tonight godfeld loves those
Congressional cutaways Bernie Sanders
blowing his nose in a handkerchief you
know AOC giving someone the side eye
that's what Greg really cares about at
the State of the Union what is Greg
going to be looking for tonight well
I'll tell you what I think Harold is
correct that it could be a feel-good
speech because I know I always feel good
after I puke
and there's going to be a lot of
vomiting going on because there's going
to be a lot of lying Chen saki calls him
a great amazing Storyteller that's a
long way of saying a lying sack of poop
nothing he says is true he can't even
keep the story straight this is the
problem with lying is that you keep
telling different lies and you can't
keep keep track and Chuck Schumer is
correct 40 million people may watch but
it's not by choice right when all the
networks are carrying it you have no
choice but to watch this Dreadful Affair
and again you know it's like you know I
hate to burst your balloon a little
topical humor
State of the Union used to be unified
that's correct but now it's about trying
out political campaign rhetoric on a
jaded public that's what the Democrats
do it's like a T-shirt cannon right it's
a T-shirt cannon goes off every
paragraph fires out a new platitude or a
new propaganda and then the side claps
and the other side's like this and
that's all it is once you see that you
feel that that state of the union is as
mechanical as the Hall of Presidents at
Disneyland it is Disneyland right I
can't remember but then but I have to
and I'm I think I'm going to blow your
mind or what's left of it Jesse please
um put me away Harold says it's
theatrical and he's right but the other
uh way of saying theatrical is saying
meaningless it's meaningless no one
talks like this anymore remember how all
the newscasters used to sound the same
people went to school to sound like that
sound like a newscaster then podcasting
slayed the teleprompter Cadence nobody
taught at Fox nobody talks like they're
on a teleprompter so how do you think
think people feel when they see these or
these these these flourishes of rhetoric
it now to them reeks of fakery
especially when they real when it smells
so richly like propaganda to Millions
it's just a blow to BS and it's because
our politicians haven't caught up with
the country we don't talk like this
anymore we talk completely the reason
why the five is successful is because
it's conversational we talk we don't we
we rarely use podcast we rarely use
teleprompters and so when you see
somebody up there he is like a old
Frozen robot from the Hall of Presidents
nobody takes it seriously especially
when it's a Croc so you're saying he
should bring in the T-shirt cannon yes
and this should be the T-shirt
apologies
the apologies on the back of the shirt
Dana
apologies to Jasper yes
for me well don't miss our state of the
union special coverage with Brett Bear
and Martha McCallum Dana and Harold are
going to be joining the panel down there
reacting to Biden speech and it all
starts at 8 55 Eastern do not miss it hi
winner Brian Kilmeade I want you to do
me a favor I want you to click to
subscribe to the Fox News YouTube page
this is the only way that I know for
sure that you're not going to miss any
great commentary any great news bites
any great interviews coming your way on
Fox you can get it all here on YouTube
so subscribe right now